yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is going to be a fun one
because it's a video that have never
done before type of video yeah what I'm
going to do in this video is I'm going
to yeah draw on the winners of the
chasuble keep it simple money for book
launch competition that's complicated
yeah okay in the book this one or the
moon the background was released on 20
days ago roughly yeah a little bit more
than two weeks and we started a
promotion competition more more so with
17 prizes that include first of all 10
copies of the book signed copies of the
book then we have six chasuble pro
memberships and then the grand prize is
a one-to-one chess lesson Skype call
yeah discuss chest whatever you want
with me so we've got 17 prices and I was
supposed to draw the prices all live in
the video and I actually did do that in
the first take of the video when I drew
the first 10 winners of the signed
copies the problem I ever was I didn't
quite know how this worked and the bad
thing was it had all the personal
information of the winners in the video
so I had to do a second take so you have
to believe me that the first 10 I drew
like 20 minutes ago and I can show you
the page now you cannot see the emails
anymore that's really good so we've got
10 10 winners there for the signed
copies of my book and I'm going to read
out first names and their location so
you will be probably able to identify
yourself and you will definitely get a
mail from chasuble
so that you can sort out yeah the
shipping address and so on so we've got
10 winners and we've got the first one
is I mean from Germany and I know him
personally that's a really fun one but I
drew it it's just what happened so then
we've got
from arlington USA Ellen from Manila and
the Philippines
then Toni from Winnipeg and Canada Felix
from eunuch Germany Michael from person
- me - glasses Delta Canada mark from ah
who's in Denmark Jake from London Anish
not an experience that would be fun
this is unease from Houston and Andre
from Auckland so these are the ten
winners of the signed copies of my book
and I drew them as mentioned 20 minutes
ago but it had all the information on
the winners which is not so great let's
not show all those information now the
next one there's six chess super pro
memberships this is some six chess about
for membership for two years I have to
add which is great value the pro
memberships and chasuble include a
couple of really great benefits you have
for example the option to get unlimited
free courses you have improved
possibilities for for studying yeah like
you have ever this day I cannot really
have them on my head
you can ya review difficult moves better
you can set your custom study depth or
kind of nice benefits and this is two
years
chasuble pro membership so let's do that
I'm going to do that live now draw
winners and then see what happens
okay now witness to draw also I draw six
winners I did that before with the ten
no repeat winners yeah okay six so these
are the six chasuble pro memberships i
know i okay and then they add them down
there so now you don't really see a
little bit of it yeah that we have now
eleven twelve and so on and they all
still obscure that's very good so um
yeah the first winner of a chess table
pro membership is Eve Eve yeah difficult
in
in English from Ghent in Belgium then
blue from Ohio USA nowhere city's
specified then Olivia from Zurich in
Switzerland then drawn from Akkad in
Germany this is just around the corner
from here maybe I know this person I
don't know next one is Larsen Larsen be
her friend of Bend Larson's probably
from from Italy and then we've got
charts from the Bronx New York USA okay
so we've got six chasuble pro membership
winners great and now the final one the
the grand prize is the lesson with me
lesson is a really general term about
that I've done this before when I had a
simultaneous display once and the price
was a chess lesson with me and we kept
on chatting for three three hours on all
kinds of things it was really fun so um
let's see who wins the grand prize there
so that's strong the winner one winner
yeah of course let's see I should be
right down there at the bottom of the
list and it is Mika Ellis from Cyprus
that's a good one probably he will be
able to identify himself there if he
watches the video and he will get of
course also the notification from
chasuble yeah so we've got the 17
winners um I'm happy to have this
competition it was a real fun thing we
had more than 5,000 entries which is
really really great and yeah hope you
enjoyed to watch the video even if you
have not won yourself I think it's
always good to share out is um yeah she
had the fun of other said same okay
thank you for watching I'll be back soon